ازمه البصل تشعل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
منذ اسابيع من عروس تحمل باقه من البصل
الى البصل يساوي دولار وغيرها في العديد
من الحالات التفاعل واذا عدنا الى اساس
المشكله فانخفاض انتاج البصل في ابرز
دولتين مصدرتين الهند باكستان بسبب سيول
وفيضانات الحقت اضرارا كبيره بمواسم البصر
اخذت معها ازمه البصل طابعا عالميا لاسيما
بعد ارتفاع سعره بشكل جرني وشهد سعر كيلو
جرام الواحد من البصل ارتفاعا خلال الاشهر
الاخيره في الفلبين ليصل الى 800 بيسو اي
نحو 16 دولارا داخل متجر العاصمه مانيلا
وتخطى سعر البصل في الاسواق اسعار الدجاج
واللحوم في لبنان ضجه الوسائل الاعلاميه
بخبر ارتفاع سعر كيلو جرام البصل الى
70000 ليره وذلك بعد التدهور سعر صرف
الليره في السوق الموازيه حيث وصل الى نحو
70,000 ليره ايضا كما قفزت اسعار البصل في
ليبيا بنسبه 300% خلال الشهر الجاري
بالمقارنه مع اسعاره خلال شه رين يناير
وفبراير
[موسيقى]